[Musique]
acteur majeur dans les domaines de
l'insertion de l'éducation et de la
jeunesse à la Réunion le département
renouvelle cette année sa participation
au Salon de la formation et de
l'orientation qui ouvrait ses portes aux
Réunionnais ce vendredi 24 février au
Parc des Expositions de la norvède à
Saint-Denis lycéens étudiant public en
recherche d'une orientation
professionnelle nombreuse et ceux à
venir se renseigner sur le stand du
département et pour cause la
collectivité propose un éventail de
dispositif en faveur de l'insertion
alors ce matin
qui est à la fois chef de fil dans l'axe
de l'action sociale et de l'insertion à
la Réunion mais également un opérateur
direct dans l'accompagnement des publics
notre rôle c'est vraiment de faciliter
les parcours des personnes les plus
fragilisées soit par l'âge le handicap
ou le chômage et notamment les
bénéficiaires du RSA ou les jeunes
recherche d'insertion alors ce salon
nous permet d'aller vers les publics en
recherche d'insertion et mieux faire
connaître notre offre d'accompagnement
mais également les mesures mobilisables
en soutien à l'heure des démarches je
pense notamment au fond des départements
aux nouveaux pattes citoyens mais aussi
à l'intérêt des métiers des services à
la personne qui offre de réels
opportunités d'insertion et puis ce
salon c'est aussi une nouvelle occasion
pour nous d'assurer la promotion de
l'allocation d'insertion de retour à
l'emploi le R+ qui je rappelle permet
aux bénéficiaires du RSA qui entame une
formation rémunérée de cumuler les
allocations y compris les salaires tirés
de la formation pendant la durée du
parcours mais aussi à l'issue de la
formation si le parcours se construit
pendant trois jours les agents du
Département
seront présents pour orienter et
informer le public afin d'accompagner
efficacement les jeunes Réunionnais dans
leur parcours professionnel
[Musique]